hey youtubers is charles is gonna be my
Flash Episode 9 video
merry Christmas to everyone the writers
went way above and beyond the call
putting in as many Easter eggs as
possible really big Easter eggs
in we had a really awesome cameo from
the original plaster is up
all explain everything so just careful
responders in the episode if you haven't
seen it yet but starting with top five
moments
number five the reverse flash has been
back for a while
and is love that Cisco tried to calm the
opposite flash
greatest almost name ever maybe discuss
the river spices such a big character
just added to any but the man in yellow
as the compromise the episode
had been searching for something for
weeks really that mercury labs
tacky on generator I think that in
combination with the star lab
treadmill will be the stand in for the
cosmic treadmill he also
directly challenge barry which is a
little bit different from the professors
in character in the comic books
he was just a little bit more evoked the
hunter solo monsoon was the one who was
pushing the flash to be better
is on really perverted twisted way at
some point all the river splashes go a
little bit nuts
if you're a little bit confused about
what was happening when they were
fighting in the stadium there were
lights flashing around them while they
were standing still
in from the camera it implies that there
are two versions
up their characters in that time and
space like the older virgins themselves
or from another time and place
chasing each other around just like they
were around perry's mother's murder
time is a weird thing they have yet to
explain how they're gonna treated
in that time causality loop previously I
thought that there was more than one
version of the reverse flash to be with
the on-screen
and as we saw during the episode when
they captured the river splash in
attacking a generator
any pulled hairs and was inserted
beating on him there really were to them
like that wasn't him punching himself
the real question is what is his next
move
and how often he is he going to appear
in the back after the season number four
that barry iris Eddie ship turns into a
full-blown triangle
most people don't like the romance the
part of the episodes
but this is really important for the
flash rebirth storyline
if you have read the comic books in you
know what happens to hundreds on one's
character
I do feel like a teeth on is Hunter's
Oman
just with a different name they're just
simple findings little bit
in making him part of the on lineage
I think in order to drive a rift between
there are three characters by the end of
the season
they started barry on the path you know
telling iris I love you
we've seen a little bit attention
building any starting to pick up what
barry's doing
I think that is going to build a bill to
the end of the season when they have a
big blowout
hundreds of them on and Wally West I
mean is a different flash in the comics
but they're just
you know like a sensible findings they
were good friends before they had their
big falling out
and he went on to become that you know
really normal character he does in the
comics
to try and avoid rampant spoilers for
people have read the comics
I will say it's not the most exciting
part of the episode but I'd
did love the fact that barry give her a
ring so many flash ring references in
this episode
in the key that any given iris also been
another ring
outages lost my shit ended in so
hilarious at various points in the
comics
the flashing is just served as a
containment unit for barry's
in the flashes suits the different
flashes professor zoom also has 12
as you see no break us then does not
have a flattering or he has not gotten
his yet
it's possible that they could do
something different but the show and
make it make the ring
just icky which FTP to nice metaphor
with the gifts that
eddie and Perry gave the iris the ring
is
a key see how that works out I think
that also implies that iris
is going to be a point of contention
coming up to the finale should be a
focal point for the flashes battle with
the reverse flash
which is also something from the comics
thought this is why you need to read the
comics
it's all in there it's on flash rebirth
number three teen McGee Amanda pays
cameo
so he didn't recognize yr Tina McGee was
Amanda pays
the actress who also starred in the
original flash show with john wesley
shipp
they've been really good about bringing
actors from the original show back the
just cast Mark Hamill as the trickster
on the show
to play an older version is character
but he also played the trickster
on the classic series he and john was a
shipwrecked we talk to each other on
Twitter it was really funny
jet I master come into central city true
to form to give doctor mcginnis really
awesome backstory
she's working at Mercury labs as in Max
mercury
also want the speedsters part in a flash
family that is that's a nice Easter Egg
I don't think that's gonna go anywhere I
think they give the competing lab that
name is no mileage
I don't think we're gonna see max
mercury other it is possible we could be
someone from his family
to be honest really anything's possible
air his true
limits with when it sent from the comics
the flash just blown right through that
with superpowers so we could totally see
a lot of other members the flesh family
they were reconfirmed that Wally West is
going to be a thing
but not for a while now for a long time
number two
firestorm is back and kicking ass I
think I mentioned in my last video but
when he bought
of the river splash that's what his
powers again look like I'm Journal have
a totally tricked out star labs cost him
that looks little bit like it does in
the comics if bring Custance
flash sued is any indication the Pride
just make it a little more subtle
but as here's more said on his life they
will bring running back
which sounds so much more awesome given
the post credits scene
is made and so much more sinister is
also the keel insiders to
it said she's going to break her morals
bend any rule
for Ronnie like that so much she cares
about him so I'm really interested to
see she betrays the group at some point
for Ronnie
or to try and see running from something
given the new dynamic with hairs in
Wells now to get a lot more confusing
think about it this way: key on snow is
so much more unpredictable now that she
knows that ron is alive
it is really awesome layer of complexity
Dec danielle Panabaker scare curso
I think she's gonna have a lot more fun
playing kitman snow in the back after
the season
if there's anything that the flash is
done really well its
make really amazing complex characters
nothing is more frustrating than see a
character that's stuck in the living
room so to speak
you know like gary said I've been stuck
in that living room ever since he killed
my mother
this is a site engine if all they talk
about him visiting all those places
around the earth
is any indication he's prolly gonna do
that like in between seasons his pride
gonna run around visit places
back to write email though so yeah he is
totally messed up in his head
as far as we know it the only people
inside their our doctor Martin Stein
in Rainier a man's character they've
also cast Jason rush
and they refer to something as the
firestorm program something that Martin
Stan was working on
I don't know how the cheese and rushed
character is going to work
with Martin Stein in running Raymond I
don't know if they're all three gonna be
in there at the same time or not
I'm you will find out the next time we
see 'em we will see them again within
the first couple episodes in the back
after the season
but really excited to see Robin on the
show he hasn't
turned into much a character so far like
the other hand might have a chance to
stretch is
acting muscles so just quickly get some
more scenes and gets turned into a
real care direct right now he's more of
a light show so to speak
and a lot of tomorrow people are really
excited to see him back especially now
that he can totally cameo on a rope
and by number one moment up course here
some wells
post credit seen a lot if you ask me
questions on Twitter
about what it means with the flash ring
in the reverse flash too tacky on
generator
so here's what I think is going on
here's in Wells is an older version
up professor zoom like it's the same
person but we're just seeing them
at different points in their time line
so the river slashed gets caught in
attacking on generator
is just a younger version that has
started the time travel loop
he's trying to affect history with the
tacky on generator which is why
here some wells Jackson onto a suit but
in order to make all those things
possible
he has to preserve the time line and a
certain way so that means that Grant
Gustin have to become the flash
so that he can become professors im
Sunday that's why welles
killed Simon stag he wants to protect
Barry Allen so he can grow up
and do something presumably that leads
to professor zoom
are embarked on everyone think about him
getting his powers this is where I think
we could possibly get into hundreds of
them on territory because it's possible
that any thought on is the father
appears in Wells
or at least one of his progenitors
here's an well seems like he's from way
way in the future
but based on the time line in the
newspaper it's a little hard to tell how
far in advance he is
he could be anything on Sun or he could
be his grandson
or his great great great great great
grandson they will answer that by the
end of the season
gonna prograde really does get confusing
is is
appears in Wells is the older version of
the character a bit a bard on character
why does he need to go back in the loop
if the younger one already did
in my head I'm thinking about it is like
a rehearsal time loop
so we can work it out in bonus videos as
we move forward
I'm sure they'll give us more
information about it the pretty good
about explain things on the show
let me know that what was your favorite
moment from the episode and do you think
pierson wells is like a child or
great-great-great grandchild
%uh eighty Don their couple
possibilities he could be a descendant
of Grant Gustin
he has the class ring but embarked on
also had a flattering
other theories that turned out to not be
true I loved the idea the Gideon
may be a virgin at Skeets in there may
be some sorta
mister gold easter egg in there clearly
that has been proven to not be true but
I still like the idea it is possible we
get the Booster Gold at some point
some really important moments that we
tab remember though anything on
knows about medicaments prolly gonna
find out the berry is the flash
tape I will develop a friendship and
then something crazy will happen without
love triangle that'll blow it up in
their faces
it's possible they could put a hundred
dollar-a-month storyline for him in the
season 2
I don't think that the wait that long
need any pretty good job just delivering
things like a really broad for instance
they didn't waste any time in ruling
that out so lot of things happening
really quickly
the roads are coming back in the next
episode oh that's been through the
teasers the next episode
roads revenge which is also a comic book
story line
if you wanna learn all about it just
three drug prevention project John story
totally awesome I think that took place
during final crisis: already mentioned
most the Easter eggs
but is one more about max mercury when
here said well said
that they were bribe als a bus the rival
was one of the first perverse flashes
max mercury ended up taking him out but
also ended up dying in doing so
the rival into taking his persona in
this before it's just kinda disappearing
into nothingness
are disappearing to this be force itself
so business references to the rival the
original perverse flash
and Max mercury the other is triggers
flashpoint
although time travel is a big part a
flash rebirth which is a completely
different story line
that involves Berry's mother flashpoint
is also a time travel story where
barry accidentally changes things in it
goes really really badly
the turn it into an animated movie
seeking to check it out just called
Justice League flashpoint
it's possible that they could turn that
into like a season 2 thing
pick it puts things into a flashpoint
territory which also involves professors
in the professors inversion the reverse
flash
it's like a very Tony Stark situation
where the hero ends up causing the
problem and then has to fix it himself
there's also the gift that barry gave to
hear some wells wrapped in a very blue
looking wrapping paper
I decided that is cobalt blue wrapping
paper
cobalt blue was another reversed flash
that was part update on lineage
but was actually a blood relative %uh
Barry Allen it's time you why me
like he ended up getting raised by fans
but genetically he was related to Barry
Allen
overall I give the absurd a saute it was
amazing into an amazing first happen
season
all the new comic book shows we've been
getting this season the flash I feel
has been the home run everything else is
being judged by the benchmark tits at
it is a little unfair just because the
team from a row the creative team is the
one to develop the flashed
because a row is one of the most
successful if not the most successful
comic book show in recent memory it just
answer resent that
anything else that they would do would
also be just as awesome that doesn't
mean that it's all perfect but it means
their head and shoulders be on like what
David Goyer love the other studios are
doing
there are a whole lot a new car pictures
coming I'm optimistic about summer them
cautiously optimistic about the rest I
am kinda worried about the crypt on one
one of the things I think this episode
did really well though was
deliver really big moments they were
tied to really big character arcs
like it wasn't just that the big reveal
the just rolled out like they'd been
developing runny Raymond as a character
as i DNK once had for a long time
so when we see the emotion are based on
actual bills
real in the payoff is just so much
bigger when he rolls in like the
CallerID to help Barry Allen
trees not much of a character yet but
that will come in time
I think my favorite drink us the moment
was the scene he had with john was the
ship
the man in yellow has taken an uppermost
do not let him take anymore
so glad that they gave the original
Clash for the original TV flash
that great moment they really do take
care their stars
I'd say up all the characters that I'm
most excited about it's really the
eighty
on character they really wait a while to
start using him i think is a must like
the first four episodes before Ethan get
some real moments
me now we understand why I mean they're
just slowly teasing
this on lineage out but the river splash
so excited to find out which direction
they're going
like I said no I mean generally just
take flash rebirth
as the baseline they're gonna modified
things little bit the mix and match with
new 52 elements
but generally flash rebirth is the
homework but you need to do if you wanna
learn about in the comics
air that is really awesome thing with
the female characters with the secondary
female characters
Butler olympia at this season that I'm
hoping that it does with Candace patents
character in the second half the season
the only reason I haven't been a huge
fan for it is because he hasn't had a
chance to get some real pathos
I mean yeah she's a blogger she works at
the coffee shop now the love triangle is
turning into a thing
I think we'll get some more interesting
drama a rose also kinda playing with the
idea
love triangle as long as they don't lean
on it too hard I think it'll be
interesting
it's mostly bare Eddie barry
relationship that I think we'll be
watching
iris is just like the wheel around which
they turn and I just can't say enough
about Tom Cavanagh
he just like the most amazing character
on the show i think i sat on my older
videos
you know the only reason that actors
like him who actually can leave their
own shows
take smaller roles like this is because
they turn into much bigger roles
which obviously totally just happened
and in the process
he is also using his spare time to
create genetically enhanced guerrillas
about the antagonist in this new season
of comic book TV
he's definitely the most fun to watch
soaked -ism
great sentimental character moments
mixed in with some huge action set
pieces and WTF reveals
firestorm gonna be so much awesome
reverse flash
can't wait to see more of him especially
with the tacky on generator
faster than light travel rembert thats
time travel right there
so do not forget big stuff happening
tomorrow a row
rage alcool so if you haven't read that
Batman comic gonna keep talking about
it's the very first story to feature
racial goal in a Batman comics a
23 up on that I think it's number to 32
so I will post that video tomorrow I'll
try to post the Burnsville you just for
racial go tomorrow to
be sure to subscribe to get it so in the
meantime new mobile Inc
appear at the top in case you guys
watching a movie on your tablet
it seems like that over here but click
here to learn all about the river splash
in the comics the history the rear
splash and click here to get ready for
air tomorrow
the he's so much watching select of
class ring this pump each other into
tomorrow's episode